hello this is Karen and David of film
courage today we are talking with
filmmaker dean peterson you can watch
his debut feature film incredibly small
right now on vimeo for free either
search incredibly small on vimeo or go
to incredibly small calm you can also
connect with dean on twitter at peterson
cinema yeah that's great Dean we know
we're just super grateful to have you
join us here today we're looking forward
to learning all about this brave
decision of yours to take your film your
your day boo did you feature film
incredibly small and then posted on
video for free you know I you know we
find that to be incredibly courageous we
ourselves we're getting ready to release
our film goodbye promise in a little
over a month so you know we're really
curious to hear kind of about this the
strategy this decision of yours and the
lessons that you've already gained from
it so thank you oh yeah thanks for
having me yeah well you have a back
story that i love you wrote i believe it
was on your site somewhere you said that
you were bagging groceries at whole
foods and unfortunately you hated it
we've all had jobs like that so we can
relate and so you quit and then you move
back to Minnesota and seven months later
you were on the set making incredibly
small looking back do you now regret
quitting that job in any way or was it
the right decision no i mean i think it
was definitely the right decision on a
number of fronts um I sort of feel like
when you a lot of people fall into these
kind of like almost traps of jobs where
they keep you from making films and then
eventually it kind of gets a little bit
too comfortable than you actually never
go back to making films and he just kind
of are doing whatever you're doing and
sometimes that's fine but for me it was
always kind of my nightmare scenario of
like getting a job and then you know
getting too comfortable and never making
a film and so I think I wasn't falling
into that trap at whole foods by any
means but uh it was kind of like it was
a milestone for me
life of like I'm committing to this this
is what I'm doing I'm not gonna have any
back-up plan like I'm just gonna make
this movie and see what happens okay
interesting so meal maybe it was a
blessing that you felt uncomfortable and
that pushed you ask yeah yeah the time
I'm sure I wasn't doing it that way but
in retrospect I probably was right well
before we talk about the full details of
the release can you first talked about
the premise behind the movie and also
why this is a movie that you just had to
make yeah i mean the promise by the
movie is kind of life for people right
after they graduate college and kind of
the transition from you know being in
college and kind of the reality that's
around that and kind of adult black of
responsibility and then you know you
graduate college and kind of overnight
you're instantly expect it to be like an
adult and you know pay for bills and get
a job and pay rent and all this stuff
and like a lot of people kind of
struggle with that and especially in
terms of a relationship you know
relationship in college means one thing
and it's it's kind of a little bit not
easier but like it's the the stakes are
a little bit different and then when you
graduate you know you you guys both have
jobs you probably don't like your jobs
people are starting to ask you about
marriage and it's just a lot harder and
the realities are a lot different so I
kind of was kind of interested in that
dichotomy and I had seen people who had
weathered that change and like most of
them broke up like I don't know anybody
who dated somebody throughout college
and then you know stayed together after
college and I was kind of interested in
that problem and and kind of inspecting
a little bit in a movie is that what
people turn a quarter life crisis ah
yeah probably i would assume sir okay
you know did help us put this into
perspective in terms of you know where
you are now taking a film and putting it
online for free you know what kind of
budget were you starting off with
because we know that in in in august of
2009 you turn the Kickstarter you raised
almost fifteen hundred dollars in sort
of the early days of Kickstarter I mean
was that your entire
budget for this film and how much money
did you put into the film no I mean the
budget is is kind of hard because it and
we shot the movie almost you know two
and a half or three years ago and so
we've been spending money since then but
I mean to get them up to shoot the movie
and get in the cam is probably about
like I don't have thirteen thousand
dollars or something and so kick yeah
and like you said this was we went to
Kickstarter and raised a little bit of
money through that and that was in the
infancy of Kickstarter and I think we
were one of the first feature films to
actually do it um and so that I mean
that was a good chunk of our budget
through Kickstarter and at this stage
you know through festivals and other
screenings and maybe a you know I
believe you have it on DVD as well or at
least you've sold a few dvds so I mean
have you have you seen a return of the
investment so far had have you made your
money back or no I mean we've made a
junk of it back um and maybe would be
having you know we're not rolling in
dough thing we made enough back that it
was we were able to make the people that
wanted you know to see a little bit of a
return happy and we're also kind of in
any position in our budget in that light
a lot of it was through Kickstarter or
through fundraisers um like Burke and
mortar fundraisers and so a lot of
people that were investing in the movie
were investing like you know this is a
way I'm gonna make money and so they
were more excited to like you know tell
the story and to support us as
filmmakers in and get the film off the
ground no that's right so you saw I
really it never really was the goal
though where we have to make the money
back you know it's not something where
you've ever who ever really felt that
kind of pressure you know I mean
whenever whenever people give you money
you always you know want to do your
hardest to to make them their money back
and like I said you know a good chunk of
it like I like a lot of it was
Kickstarter and fundraisers and I you
know worked at a liquor store for a
summer too and save tons of money myself
that tons of money but chunk of change
myself and so it's kind
this kind of I don't know a very motley
budget that we had but it was never like
you know we have these at this
investment group that you know is gonna
damage our credit if we don't pay back
or something you know and since we
really want to get into how you know how
you decided to release this film I mean
once we're just going to kind of just
skip all the way head here the
distribution so you know once the film
was complete what kind of distribution
were you sort of dreaming for or you
know or maybe even while you were making
the film like if you said if you were
like this is the idea way we could
release the film I mean was that going
through your mind at all in terms of the
way you wanted to release it or what you
were expecting yeah I mean of course I
sort of think that when you're a
filmmaker you kind of have to be
thinking about distribution given all
your writing editor shooting it um and
so I I had always been thinking about it
and I you know we knew that we wanted to
do a pretty extensive festival Ramon or
as extensive as possible and I from you
know from the beginning I had always
wanted to put the film online and I
didn't know what manifestation I was
going to take whether it be enough
elixir iTunes or putting it on youtube
or whatever but that had always been a
kind of Colonel in the back of my mind
and so kind of going into it we you know
finished the film um we submitted to a
bunch of festivals we premiered it in
London and then we kind of had this
rollout of festivals throughout the year
and we were looking at different
distribution options and strategies and
how much it would cost and we kind of
made took a lot of factors into
consideration and we at the end of the
day once we were done with festivals and
the feet the actual dates we kind of saw
that it made the most sense and it was
our best option to do an online rollout
for release so that was always part of
the plan was to submit to film festivals
was it yeah I mean we didn't we didn't
exactly we didn't have a civic festival
in mind and we submitted to a ton of
festivals and we thought that rain dance
was the best option for us and it was a
really great experience and was a great
place to primeira phone
and so how many film festivals rejected
you before you initial it were doing
that um into rain dance how many oh and
I mean I I don't know I don't know how
many before me we got rejections from a
lot of fun festivals we I mean I had a I
was keeping a running spreadsheet of you
know the festival's be submitted to and
got it too didn't get into and I'm sure
that anybody who's submitted the film
festivals can tell you it's kind of a
bloodbath sometimes um but I think in a
lot of ways the festival's you don't get
into is kind of a blessing because the
ones you do get into are usually really
supportive and really champion your
movie and it's always a really good
experience did you have any connections
at rain dance we didn't know and it was
kind of like my producer James that told
me just admit to aqui said it was a good
festival and they played awesome
independent movies and it was kind of a
long shot like I never thought we were
gonna actually get into rain dance um
and then we did and we didn't know
anybody there was kind of just a cold
submission and so we were pretty excited
when we got in and did you attend the
festival let's see the film flight yeah
we went out to London for the premiere
and it was incredible as a beautiful
Peter and like I've never been to London
before so there's a lot of fun nice and
then once you got into rain dance then
how long after that point did you get
accepted into your next festival um
don't remember it wasn't too long
afterwards I think that once we had
gotten into Rendon's we've got into
another one that was a few more that
were afterwards um and then the next one
after rain dance was like two or three
weeks or something right afterwards and
then as will happen with some festivals
like we played a random sand people saw
the movie there and then we got invited
to a couple of other European festivals
through rain dance that's great when you
sort of get that one festival and it
sort of snowballs and other festivals
where one leads to the next I mean I've
been with rain did they actually fly you
guys out or is that something where you
had to pay for your own expenses to get
out there no yeah we had to pay for our
own expenses and
I mean I'm sure as everybody knows
London it's not the cheapest city but it
was I'm really glad that we did it was a
good place and the all the people that
work at Raindance were super super nice
than they had other suggestions for
festivals that they thought would fit
well and we also went to Paris after
indents and did a screening at a college
in Paris which is really fun too I was
that almost bittersweet you know on the
one hand you get accepted into your
first festival and it's rained ang was
which is a you know we here is a
wonderful festival it's in London I mean
it's exciting but on the other hand is
like you have to get yourself therapy so
was it sort of like jeez and we have to
put in all this money and so our film
for the first time you know in another
country yeah I mean it's that's kind of
just like the name of the game you're
always kind of like spending money on
stuff that he probably would rather
spend on something else but and I
couldn't really implants was like we
know we were going to London to hang out
and go to a fun festival and so it's
kind of like I was glad to spend the
money and it was very expensive but it
was it mean is totally worth at the same
time it was a good experience and and
what what year was that what year did it
premieres like what was the date of when
we even mirrored in like October of 2010
Oh si ok so October 2010 and then and
then how long altogether were you on the
festival circuit for uh I mean me we
2011 was like a big festival year we
played the most of them but I mean we I
mean we played at a festival in Texas
like last month I think so we're we were
kind of still going and I guess if
anybody invited us to phone tussles now
we would still play I'm just not
actively like pursuing them anymore um
but I mean yeah we did it for almost a
couple years a year and a half two and a
half years I guess yeah that's not it
sounds about right i mean and so that
entire time were you like seeking a
distributor like I mean as that was that
part of which were you know we were
hoping with the film you know cuz that's
generally the filmmakers do it's like
you know you go one test last another
and it's like and you're kind of hoping
that that someone's going to come across
it and some sort of deal is going to
going to happen some at some point along
the way yeah I mean we were always
looking
distribution options and we were kind of
had you know a pretty healthy festival
run which is kind of like I feel like
the first phase of any distribution plan
is you know doing festivals and getting
it out there and getting reviews and
stuff like that and so we kind of had a
pretty long one and we were talking to
people and looking at the different
distribution options and avenues um and
that we we talked to a lot of people who
you know liked our movie and wanted to
work with us and stuff and there weren't
really any like options that we thought
were like exactly what we wanted to do
and we were kind of in the unique
position where a movie didn't really
cost so much money and so we weren't you
know we didn't have you know a huge debt
hanging over our head of we you know we
really need to pay this money back it
was kind of like well let's find the the
best fit for our movie for the
distributions that we can release it the
way that we want to and so while it was
on the festival circuit of me were you
investing a lot of time and energy
seeking that traditional distribution I
mean was it something where you were
just kind of like hoping they would
discover you or was it something where
you were sending all screeners and
impress kids and and and really trying
to get that written or inviting them to
various screenings I mean how active
were you seeking the traditional
distribution rock yeah I mean it's kind
of like a give-and-take like you know
people will kind of email you out of
blue with from distribution companies
and and then we were also sending out
screeners to specific companies that we
were interested in and wanted to talk to
so it's kind of like a little bit of
both and we're also kind of like
formulating because I worked for an
infinite distribution company called
arranged like I came in for a while and
um they kind of have the model of just
taking movies out on the road and so we
were exploring that option as well and
kind of pricing out the budget for what
that would be so we kind of had like a
lot of balls in the air at once um
for most of the festival run and we knew
that we wanted to get as many festivals
out of the way before we did
distribution um because kind of wants
you to you know take it out and put it
in theatres and stuff then it's not as
attractive for festivals and so we kind
of wanted to wait until we were done
doing the festival circuit looking back
on it now I do you wish that you had
skipped the festival circuit entirely
and that you should have just made me
gone right to vimeo to release it or
were you happy with the progress that it
took no i mean uh vessels were a great
experience i mean we you know we got it
to a lot of different cities we probably
wouldn't have gone to um we got a lot of
great reviews from it i met like a lot
of great filmmakers and different people
that I worked at the festivals and so I
mean it was a really good experience and
it's kind of like almost a necessary
component to kind of gain you know some
press and like some credibility for your
phone I think um and so I think it it's
kind of a kick I mean I guess it could
work to skip the festival circuit but
you're not really like losing anything
by doing festivals you only have stuffed
a game by playing at them hmm well can
you bring us to to your decision to
release the film for free we hear so
many times that oh don't give step away
because it diminishes value but we're
kind of on the fence about that
ourselves um how long had you been
thinking about giving away the film for
free and was there a part of you inside
that said I'm scared what if no one
wants to watch it you know I mean can
you can you kind of talk about what your
process was yeah I mean I had been
really really interested in the model of
artists giving away other stuff for free
for a really long time and it's always a
appeal to me and it was always kind of
like I had always admired people that
had done it and net I mean I had always
been in the back of mind of like oh that
would be kind of cool if we did this but
it always seems like kind of like a huge
risk or like a big extremely bold move
or something and so it never really came
to my mind is like
you know this is something we definitely
should do until sometime last year I can
t remember when um but it was um I don't
know it just kind of after I had thought
about it for a while it just kind of
seemed like it wasn't actually that big
of a risk because it's like I mean
you're not giving it away for free kind
of in a lot of people's minds seems like
oh you're just kind of you know you're
not going to make any money you're just
kind of wasting it or you know throwing
it away and I think that that mode of
thinking is kind of misguided I think
that there are a lot of ways to make to
monetize it and you can make money off
of doing it and think with a lot of
planning them like a lot of creativity
and utilizing all these new technologies
that are emerging and film and on the
internet and stuff I think you can
actually make your money back and I
think um hopefully more people will
utilize it there are a lot of people
that have been writing about you know
them means a special to go three and or
the pay what you want model and for the
most part been wildly successful when
people do that they actually make more
money than if they had charged you know
the traditional price for a CD or
whatever they're there someone why did
you choose video over YouTube um we
actually it is actually on YouTube um it
hasn't been getting as many views as you
typically have been pushing it as much
um but video I've been kind of
concentrating on and that's the one I've
been sending out in links and impressed
kids and stuff because the vimeo whose
community is very very strong and it's
all or it's not all but it's comprised
of a lot of independent filmmakers and
artists and film enthusiasts and it's a
it's a lot smaller community than um
youtube but i think that um the quality
for lack of a better word is better um
it's you know it's a lot of directors
and dps and editors and just a lot of
really interesting talented people or
neural it's a very supportive community
there's no like you know people trolling
your your comments section that's all
people saying like oh this is
look great like what camera did you use
all right it's a very intelligent
helpful friendly question um it was more
of a Q&A I was screaming than it does it
was like people just kind of I don't
know making weird offensive comments in
the concert and so um i don't know if i
use vimeo personally and i love it I
mean it was looks so good the
communities so good all the videos that
people put up a really great um and so
it was kind of just the brand I debated
but you haven't done anything to lose I
putting out on both we might as well
just make it available to whoever wants
to watch it now forgive us Dean you know
we have a cat that is on the other side
of this door that's like the alley these
time I think I think we got an area we
got a letter yes what happens when your
home turns into a studio okay come on
okay very okay Joe comp the house Jesus
that she has to be in here with us she
won't see her the answers to so yeah she
actually has a big question except no
you know but speaking of sort of vimeo
and youtube I mean had you considered
any other platforms amid had you looked
into like voted no vote on it or like
bittorrent or anything like that in
terms of giving your movie white for
free ya know me we considered a lot of
different options i mean we pretty much
looked at every platform on the internet
and I mean we also did look at kind of a
paywall of you know period pay five
bucks and you can watch this movie or
give us your email address and you can
watch this movie and it kind of boiled
down to like my goal is just get it to
as many people as possible um as easily
as possible and the thing that I liked
about Vimeo is like uh is that you can
just play it instantly um in really high
quality there's no ads there's no popups
there's no pay wall it's just seamless
and easy and you can all the other big
thing for me is that I'm vimeo you can
embed it
like blogs and on Facebook and so if if
somebody watches movie and they really
like it instead of just emailing a link
to their friend they can say like here
is the movie itself like this movie is
really great watch this you just have to
press play and there it is its immense
oh I think that kind of curation is like
really interesting really exciting and I
think it's a rip a new development and
the big death I'm just telling your
friend to go to a theater and go to the
movie it's like you know here is the
movie like right here um and so it's
kind of like in this keem of online
being a mode of distribution for films
it's kind of like you know your fans are
doing a lot of the legwork and they're
kind of becoming their own distributors
and holding your own screaming's by
posting on their Facebook wall your
actual movie or posting on their blog
your movie um and so that idea really
excited me and a lot of these other like
video platforms on the internet you
can't do that or it's kind of annoying
because you have to the register or send
in your email address or something so I
wanted this very seamless very painless
necklace a platform to put the movie on
and Vimeo is the best option for all of
this yeah absolutely yeah thank thank
you for for highlighting that theme you
know and give us the goods here in terms
of cuz you know it's one thing to say
okay this is how we're going to do it
but I obviously those preparation you
know that that goes into it you know cuz
so far the film has been seen almost
30,000 times on video you know so what
kind of effort did you put in I mean it
wasn't just merely the fact that just
like okay here's the film let's put it
on vimeo and now let it go to work i
mean what what were you doing before him
yeah well I mean we're doing a lot of
stuff before Ian the main thing that we
did before was the night before we um
put it online we had a free screening in
Brooklyn at the rerun theater and we the
rerun theatre is great theatre um where
there's like a bar and restaurant
attached to it and so we kind of had
this we've just like kind of release
party where um you know people could
come and watch the movie for free
and hang out and drink beer and stuff
and then my only like caveat of the
thing was you know if you liked this
movie go home and help us spread the
word by blogging about it by emailing
your friends by tweeting about it and um
so we kind of invited a lot of our
friends and a lot of people that you
know use social networks very heavily
and just kind of encourage them to have
fun and then go home and blog about it
um and we got a lot of them did and a
lot of them we got a really great
response from that and then the other
tier of it was that we did a lot of
preparation work beforehand of you know
sending out emails to websites to
journalists to you know bloggers I'm
just kind of letting them know what this
is what we're doing you know this is
where you can see it um and then the day
of and like in the days following we
also did a lot of social network
outreach of going on tumblr and twitter
and facebook um encouraging people that
if they liked it you know all you had to
do is reblog it or post on your facebook
wall and so that kind of curation by a
people that have seen it already it kind
of creates like a network of you know
their followers can wash it and then if
they like they blog about it then their
followers watch it and so that's kind of
what we were allowed on the most and it
was the most effective I think of
getting people to watch it because you
know if your friend says this movie is
really great like that's a lot more
effective than anything really i think
well how many people are on this team I
mean besides the friends and family that
you've asked to spread the word about it
where those are like a core group of
people that were set to do all this
legwork I mean yeah like most of it was
me and my producers tanem James um but
it was also like you know I emailed all
the actors and all the crew and stuff
and I was like hey we're putting some
line you know I'm sure a lot of your
funds have been wanting to watch this
and so like here's a link to it and so
they took their twitters and their
facebooks and blogs and we're like hey
here's this movie that I was in it was
movie I worked on and so
was kind of we had a kind of poor with
me at the memory son are doing a lot of
it and then it was also just the people
that had worked on or were involved in
our friends who were excited to see it
um just kind of helping to spread the
word a lot and that's that's what's kind
of great about the putting in on videos
that you know people that are excited
about it can have a really huge impact
on the viewership of spreading it so
easily and and so quickly you know just
just coming back I mean really help here
Dane is if you don't mind maybe being a
little bit more specific in terms of how
many of these social media people came
out to the screening can you give us an
idea like the screening beforehand and
then also when you when you started
sending out um you know emails and such
to bloggers and and and champions and
that sort of thing I mean how many he
knows did you send out in those very
early days um you know a couple weeks
ago yeah um I mean well at the screening
a lot of it was like it was we had a
free screening and get the rerun is kind
of a notoriously fun theatre to go see
movies that and so a lot of there was
like a couple of like meetup groups that
came um and there was a couple of I
think there was like a college class or
something I came um so there were just a
lot of people that had kind of found out
about it through the grapevine um and a
lot of my friends in New York are very
active on social networks and so and it
wasn't it wasn't like a manipulative
thing and it's just like I had vited my
friends and they blogged about it as a
lot of people do these days and then
after or before the screening I mean I I
don't know a number of emails a lot of
emails to people and some of them were
kind of dead ends as you know will
always happen but a lot of them a lot of
people were really excited and a lot of
questions and we're kind of excited to
promote this model of you know giving a
root movie with free online and so I
wasn't really a tough sell for a lot of
people because it was just kind of like
what was crazy guys are doing this let's
talk more about this well of those
emails that you wrote do you remember
how many
were actually personal where you address
people by name or where most of them
sort of just a PR blast how did you do
it no i mean i don't really i try not to
do PR blasty he knows cuz they're
usually not effective i usually just
reach out to people i like like you guys
were I'm like you know I've been
interested you guys for a long time like
here's this thing I'm doing you know I
think you might be interested in for
this reason um because i feel like if
unless you personalize nima i look like
you know this is a topic you guys talk
about or seem to be interested in then
it's kind of like oh it was just another
movie worked as if you're like hey you
know John I heard you talk to this
person about you know alternative
distribution methods like this is what
I'm doing you might be interested in it
and so I feel like eat if you send less
of those kind of targeted emails they're
much more effective than just kind of
like a boilerplate that you kind of just
bc see a bunch of people to you know
it's what do you bring that updated it
forgive me if I'm going to embarrass you
here but you know I thought when you
sent this email I thought it was very
simple I thought it was very effective
and I have it here I mean would it be
too much if I you know cuz it's rather
short you know would you would you mind
if I read it for those they're gonna
come across dunno I mean I hope there's
no typos or anything
yep o thou let me visit I cuddle up here
oh alright alright here it is alright so
you know this is this is what being
wrote to us and obviously that this led
to this conversation here today he just
simply wrote hey guys my name is dean
peterson I'm a filmmaker from Brooklyn
and a longtime fan of your work I wanted
to email you really quickly because I
made a feature film called incredibly
small that I am self-releasing right now
I put it online for people to watch for
free and in the first week it got over
30,000 views and since it was a
low-budget movie that we decided to self
distribute I thought it might be a story
you'd be interested in you can view the
movie online for free at the link below
and then he provides the link and then
anyways I'm a huge fan of your show and
wanted to be sure to personally reach
out to you best dean peterson um and so
my question Dean you know you know did
you really mean that or is that there's
something you emailed everybody no I
mean I like a handful of I mean blog
cats instead I really really like and um
I mean aside from trying to promote the
movie i also like you know connecting
with people whose work I follow as much
as I can and so even if it's like just
another filmmaker I like who's movies I
enjoy like you know I try to reach out
to them personally and be like hey you
know like this movie is I'm similar to
your movie maybe you'd like this or I
heard you talking about this on a
podcast and so I never I mean I would
probably be too paranoid to like be
called out on it to send it out to like
some guy just some random guy or
something um and I also i don't know i
mean we're having worked in a
independent distribution with range life
you know I've sent thousands of emails
to people trying to get people to come
to movies and I've sort of found like
you know genuine sincere personalized
emails are like a thousand times more
effective than just like an e-blast like
he blasts for all intents and purposes
are kind of useless because they're not
effective at all and I know that from
personal experience when I
that might just delete them almost
immediately but if somebody is like hey
Dean you know I saw you made this movie
like and they kind of include personal
details they show that they are actually
interested and you know kind of took the
time to write a personal email and so
that goes a much much longer way I think
yeah absolutely you know I was just
teasing you earlier there Dean you know
it that's what I wanted you to talk
about I wanted you to talk about the
personal touch you know because Karen I
we do receive a good amount of inquiries
and we get an awful lot of some of these
those spam blasts we've also been guilty
of doing them ourselves because it is it
is time consuming so I was just curious
what your take is because I know
sometimes you know I've been guilty of
just for times sake i'm doing a BCC and
and so yeah and it's something to
consider it's a sort of hone our own
pitch so it's good information yeah
thank you yeah i mean i'd say it's like
you know if you were to send fit if he
very personalized genuine emails that
would be way more effective than
something 50,000 just eblast emails um
and I have no signs back that up but
just from personal experience I feel
like that's kind of my approach to
reaching out to people sure well do you
have any type of donation model in place
or a virtual tip jar or anything like
that yeah we do if you go to incredibly
small to watch movie read below there's
um a button that you can press to donate
money and then we also have a store on
the website where you can buy DVDs if
you want to as well um and we've gotten
a good response and a lot of people have
have chipped in or black v's and stuff
um and we tried to do it as nicely as
possible where you don't have to buy a
DVD to watch the movie or you know
download a file it's just kind of like
you can watch it and if you really like
it and you want to support this model
here is like a bottom to do so fine
we've gotten a good response it's been
actually kind of surprising how many
people have done hmm and of the
donations that you've received have
there been enough to pay off any
remaining money owed on the film um I
mean we kind of went into this of just
like we're gonna do this
um you know and we weren't really like
setting any metrics for like financial
gain that we hope to expect and so kind
of everything that we got was like just
kind of surprised not surprising but
like just kind of a bonus and so yeah
it's been it's been actually it's been
really great and people as kind of
expected and as people kind of talk
about it when they talk about you know
the model of free music or movies or
whatever is like you know when you do
this and you kind of do this alternative
model people kind of respect that and
want to like support it I think there
are a lot of people out there who want
to support a free model of independent
film or music or art or anything and are
willing to kind of go above and beyond
the normal viewership and kind of chip
in and donate for that you know I mean
outside of you releasing your film for
free on Vinnie I mean you know off the
top of your head how many of the
filmmakers can you think of have also
sort of just gone on the vimeo and just
what these different freedom it is this
something where you're almost pioneering
this effort because you know one thing
well we often see it's like the first
one to do it you know gets a lot of the
attention sort of comes their way and
then and then if as people follow in
their footsteps they're not going to get
as much of a spotlight yeah i mean i'm
definitely not the first one there's
been I mean I can think of a couple
office have my head um and they've all
kind of done it differently I think a
lot of people in the past have viewed
putting it on Vimeo is kind of like a
last-ditch like you know we're done with
everything else let's just throw it up
there um and I think that that's
probably not an effective way to do it
for me it was like this is the release
of my movie we're distributing the movie
now and so we put a lot of work and a
lot of effort into it um and so that it
wasn't like it wasn't kind of just like
oh we're done with everything else let's
just put it online it was kind of like
you know I treated it as if we were
gonna be playing it in 15 days across
the country in terms of work and
outreach and stuff like that
and night in like that very first day
when you know it goes live I mean for a
first off we should ask like what day
during the week was it was like was it a
monday was it a Saturday well uh it was
I think it was a Wednesday because I
think we had the screening and maybe art
on a Tuesday Tuesday so I went it's a
wednesday and so that day were you like
constantly checking in with video and
seeing like what the view count was that
or were you just sort of like you had
read your nose to the grindstone it's
just like you were just sending out
emails and just contacting people and
just and just putting the work in yeah I
mean it was mostly just emailing people
I mean the whole next day I was just you
know people nonstop I'm trying to get
people to reblog it on Twitter and on
Facebook and Tumblr and stuff um and so
it was we were mostly just kind of busy
doing that and then I think either the
day after that or two days after that it
was on the featured page on vimeo and
that's when the views really started to
skyrocket and so we got that's more when
we were interested in the shoes instead
of you know just emailing non-stop so
what kind of results did you get early
on like that first day before vivio so
that the staff picked it up and
recommended it where were you at in
terms of your own efforts well we knew
that there's this really great book and
I mean while we're talking about
distribution Chris Anderson wrote this
book called free which is all about
artists giving away their um product for
free and why it's actually really viable
exciting option and that the book really
inspired me to do this myself but he
kind of talks about there's a
statistical model almost of of you know
viewership or whatever it is you're
looking for buying people buying your
album or downloading a movie or whatever
and it's kind of like I don't know the
mathematical term but it's like it
spikes and then it kind of trails off
after that so within the first like you
know week or even three or four days you
really need to get as many views as
possibly can
because then it inevitably will start to
trail off after that and it will reach a
plateau at some point and so we were
really really focused on the first days
of like you know we really need to get
as many people to watch this as possible
in terms of emails and outrage and stuff
like that and I think it was the second
or third day that it was on vimeo um and
so oh I mean we did get just the blind
share of of using the first few days I
think like the second day we got like
10,000 views or something like that so
okay so your offer your efforts paid off
right away and did you did you did you
contact vimeo like through like a
personal email I mean did you get in
contact with their staff or they somehow
saw the effort and and and and somehow
it came across their channels without
you actually reaching out to them ya
know me we I mean throughout the whole
life of encode was small we had been
contacting them and you know keeping in
touch with them and we had seemed that
at South by a couple times and they were
really interested I mean vimeo in
general is really supportive and you
know actually has a stake in you know
the well-being of their members and the
filmmakers that are on there and stuff
and so they were always like really
interested and excited about what we're
doing with this and other projects and
stuff like that and so we were kind of
like oh you know we should just send him
an email let him know what we're doing
what we're thinking you know this is
what we're doing a release in movie um
and they got around to watching it and
really liked it um we got a really good
response from them and then so then a
couple of days after they'd seen it I
think they put it on the future page
well you know in addition to the 38,000
views that you've racked up to this
point and you just mentioned sort of the
benes of benefits of free and can you
talk about you know aside from the view
count you know what other benefits i
have already sort of come your way um
since the release yeah i mean i think in
general it's it's just like people that
would never have even heard of the movie
have now seen it and really liked it and
you know interacted with us and we've
gotten a ton of emails from people who
said that they saw and they loved it or
they their friend recommended it to them
and they watched it and so it's just
been a lot of it's been like you know if
we
done the traditional theatrical release
of the movie they're just people that we
wouldn't have gotten a chance to see the
movie and now we've reached I mean
people and all kinds of country
different countries like different
continents all around the country I've
seen the movie and have really liked it
and I think it's kind of shown that
there is you know a market for small
independent movies and I think a lot of
times people don't view them as really
viable options or kind of saying like
that they're kind of a niche you know
commodity for lack of a better word but
then we mean we got a tremendous
response from people who have probably
never seen a low-budget movie and really
really liked it and connected with the
story and so I think that that's been
the most gratifying thing and it's also
a lot of people been like hey you know
the look you connect like projects and
so it's kind of we're kind of trying to
build you know a base of fans who are
like interested in this movie and
they're also though interested to what
we're going to do next and they're going
to you know be interested in three or
four movies from that hopefully and so
it's we're kind of treating it as like
you know trying to build a group of
people who who are you know kind of in
for the long haul and our kind of
interested to see where we go from here
do you have any additional goals or or
even expectations from this vimeo
release um I mean just to try to get as
many people to watch it i guess as
possible and I mean we've I can't really
have any complaints or anything's we far
exceeded any goals I had previously set
up and so it's kind of like everything
after this is just kind of like oh this
is this is great too um I know that I
mean we're time to like i said before
trying to get people interested in not
only this movie but you know our next
movie a movie to make after that and
kind of trying to build a sustainable
fan base that will be kind of you know
not just not just gonna watch this one
movie but kind of we're gonna follow us
throughout the years and have you put a
deadline on pushing the release is there
a time when you and your your two other
cohorts are going to stop I mean no I
mean this word it's I think it's
just going to live on vimeo people have
asked us you know like is this a goal to
try to get it onto netflix or other
platforms or something and I I always
tell them like bid no this is I mean
this is what we're doing like you know
there's no goal like I think we have
gotten a better response than I created
for the movie on netflix or other
platforms or something and so this is
kind of I mean this was our goal and
we've you know far exceeded it and so
I'm really happy with everything that's
happened to her I mean what did you
think Dean and when you put online image
you saying like okay we're it again
we're gonna get a thousand people to
watch this over to get 5,000 I mean what
was that or the expectation you had I
don't know I didn't I mean like my goal
was very low I mean if we had if a
thousand people have watched it ever
like I would have been really happy um
and so you know in the first day or two
days or whatever when it got like 10,000
I I just like I was just blown away by
the response that we got and so I mean
it far exceeded any expectations of what
we had before for sure and and so at
this stage where you are right now would
you advise other filmmakers would you
say this this is this is a wise maneuver
for them to also put their film online
for free yeah I mean there's there's so
many variables involved in it i mean if
you know if you have if you spent ten
million dollars to make your movie like
you know it might make sense to have it
be a part of your distribution scheme
that scheme but distribution plan um but
i don't know i mean i guess it all just
depends on what you want to get out of
it and i think that's an important thing
to think about when you're distributing
your movie you know do you is your main
goal to make all your money back is your
main goal to play it as many festivals
possible is that to get just as many
people to watch it as possible or you
know to build a fan base or a name for
yourself and so I think you know kind of
figuring out what you want and then I
think that there are ways to build
putting it online for free even in a
limited capacity inside like any
distribution plan you know if you're
doing you can tie it with a theatrical
model you can do it while
you're doing festivals you can do it you
know while you're selling beauties and
stuff I think that it can really work in
a lot of different capacities it doesn't
just have to be the sole method of
distribution and i can and i think that
the exciting thing is that you know
there's a ton of people who make movies
to either don't get into any festival or
get into festivals and then don't get a
distribution deal and it kind of just
left wondering what to do and so i think
that it opens up a really exciting
avenue of being able to get your movie
out to people with no other options and
i think it's it's kind of like when you
know digital cameras became prevalent
and people who previously couldn't
afford you know millions of dollars to
shoot a movie on film could now make a
feature film and it could look great and
you could you know get into festivals
and make a movie and this is kind of
opening up the same avenues of you know
previously it was really hard and
expensive to get distribution deals and
to do theatrical releases and now it's
you know we have this exciting super
awesome avenue of distribution online
which doesn't really cost much of
anything and you're able to get it to
thousands of people and so I think for
you know really low-budget independent
filmmakers it's a really exciting
prospect do you expect to see a lot more
of us yeah I mean I hope so i think and
it was it's kind of the same thing as
when we because when we did our
kickstarter it was you know almost three
years ago and it was there was almost a
stigma involved of you know asking for
money online and now everybody's doing
it and it's it's a great resource and i
think everybody recognized that and i
think that there's still a stigma with a
few people putting a movie online of its
risky or it's scary or it's bad um and i
hope that people will see that it's it's
I mean it is kind of scary but it's also
really exciting and you know the
possibilities are kind of endless for
what you can do with it and how
successful you can be with it so I hope
that people recognize that in experiment
with it and come up with new interesting
ways to incorporate it into really
strategies and so I hope in the coming
years that more people will decide to do
I think I think it is a really good
viable option lastly do you friday for
anyone that's watching this and maybe
they're sort of tinkering with this idea
what would you sort of advise them like
you know what are the steps you know
step by step how should they approach
this what should they do before they
take the leap um I would definitely
recommend reading Chris Andersen's book
free for sure it doesn't really deal
with movies per se as much but a lot of
musicians and other people that have
done similar things and so definitely
read that and also i mean just recognize
that it it's a lot of work and it's not
just kind of like deciding to put it on
line one day it's you know there's a lot
of work that goes into an advance and
you know you have to really capitalize
on first week or so because that's
probably going to be when you're going
to get the most the lion share of your
views like it granted to live on the
internet for however long you decide to
have it up and people always watch it
but you know you really need to try to
like create it mean it's the same thing
when you premier a film at a festival or
at a theater or whatever you know you
need to try to get as much buzz as
possible because the first the opening
weekend of your movie is going to be you
know when you get the most people and
you have to really try to capitalize on
that and so just you know days much
preparation work as possible looking at
other people that have released the
movies and kind of what they've done and
seeing things that they did that you
wouldn't do um I'm just I guess doing as
much homework as possible and I'm trying
to find the best way to district to
integrate it into your distribution well
Dean thank you so much for first off
writing to us and also for taking time
out of your schedule to talk to us about
the release of incredibly small thank
you yeah thanks so much for having me
I'm excited to see what you guys end up
doing good movie yeah I can we do not
adjust this conversation just it gets me
kind of juiced up because you know we we
have something we've been working on for
for quite a while so just just sort of
picking your brain a little bit and just
kind of you know comparing and
contrasting it to what we have up our
sleeve the dimittis has been this is
very really helpful
thankful to you for taking the time out
and sharing a little bit your experience
you know especially since it's so close
to our release you know so it's all its
records for a really really relevant the
information you shared with us thank you
cool thanks I'm is a pleasure
yeah oh yeah when we encourage all you
guys listening they will look for we're
going to sort of have this interview and
then we're gonna link up the movie but
underneath it so if you've watched this
you're going to do to see the movie
right with it but you can also search it
on on vimeo incredibly small or you can
simply go to incredibly small calm and
check it out and Dean we thank you for
your time yeah thank you yeah thanks so
much guys